bonjour laurent lutz merci d'être en
direct avec nous certains restaurants
restent aux portes closes d'autres
établissements ouvrent généralement
comment se positionnent les acteurs de
votre secteur professionnel le monde de
la restauration et il dit viser un petit
peu vous avez donc des gens qui
travaille essentiellement avec des
terrasses ou six jours là c'est très
compliqué à sortir sur la côte où les
terrasses sont très grandes
bon pour les autres de toute façon il
fallait faire on n'a pas tellement le
choix c'était soit une fermeture ou à l'
on accepter le pass sanitaires bon les
les gens je pense que professionnels
vont s'organiser
2 qui peut le plus peut le moins je veux
dire ils vont essayer de faire le
nécessaire
maintenant je ne vous dis pas que ça va
bien se passer partout et pour ça que je
voulais mettre en place une visio avec
le ministère de l'intérieur pour que les
restaurateurs puissent apprendre les
gestes et surtout le langage et avoir
devant quelqu'un de récalcitrants parce
que génial arrive années de ministère de
l'intérieur écoutez on attend non et
demande
samedi on doit nous répondre aujourd'hui
ou demain c'est important
et comment appliquer sur la durée
l'opération restaurants fermés pour ceux
qui ferment leurs établissements et qui
veulent protester parce que si c'est
juste fermé aujourd'hui on ouvre après
il ya un risque d'aller à l'encontre de
certaines convictions et en restant
fermée il ya aussi un risque pour les
entreprises en termes de perte de
chiffre d'affaires là bien sûr puisque
pour l'instant nous sommes bien sûr nous
allons demander des aides auprès de oddo
le maire niveau de bercy parce que
pourquoi s'il ya un manque de chiffre
d'affaires sur une baisse ça ressemble
c'est une personne n'a de boule de
cristal pour savoir le le montant de 2,2
d'affaires mais ce qui est très
important savoir qu'on est ouvert
1 on évite la fermeture parce
qu'autrement il n'y avait pas le choix
et d'en face on nous avait proposé
maintenant ce qu'on regrette on appelait
ce père et avec le conseil
constitutionnel puisse laisser quand
même libre accès en terrasse on nous a
dit
au milieu du élus de cette crise quand
evra ce n'était pas dangereux et
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu en impasse à
lutter ou aller en extérieur donc vous
craignez une baisse de la fréquentation
de nouveaux clients dans les restaurants
dans les cafés comme c'était le cas
selon les dires des cinémas et des
musées tout à fait on craint mais on n'a
pas les chiffres
on ne s'est pas observée dans les
grandes villes la période du mois
d'autres beaucoup d'établissements sont
déjà fermés 1 où je prends le pari bon
comme j'en avais qui a pas beaucoup de
tourisme de touristes étrangers
il ya quand même une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires naturel comme tous les mois
d'août donc maintenant le sujet se
posent sur les gens avec des touristes
sur la côte à côte d'azur sur la côte
aquitaine sur la côte bretonne
voilà mais ça je pense qu'on pourra
faire le point d'ici deux-trois jours
l'exécutif et de nombreux professionnels
de santé estime que la vaccination est
l'application du pass sanitaires son
seul moyen d'éviter un nouveau
confinement et la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez je dis qu'il faut que c'est la
seule solution il faut que tout le monde
puisse se faire mais on pouvoir accès il
n'y a que comme ça qu'on va réussir à
passer mon avis personnel je ne je
n'engage personne répondait alors à ceux
qui ont manifesté samedi dernier et qui
sont contre écoutez moi j'écoute aussi
tout le monde les médias
bien que 87% gens qui sont contaminés
qui sont aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
n'étaient pas vaccinés voilà et la
réponse elle est là et est ce que vous
voyez sinon une autre alternative à ce
passe sanitaires pour le secteur de la
restauration où il y en a pas
aujourd'hui j'en ai aujourd'hui j'en
vois pas vous dit il n'y a que sur les
extérieurs où je m'interroge merci
laurent lutse d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la branche cafés brasseries
établissements de
oui de l'umih l'union des métiers des
industries de l'hôtellerie